alaikum
brothers and sisters thank you for
joining us
honored guests in our
latest installment of zadil mahad we had
authored by the great
and esteemed late scholar of islam
shems
we had left off last time speaking about
the way
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
would usually make rukur
we gave a very specific description of
his rukur
i want to recap on that
when a person makes rokura he is bowing
this is what this position is it is a
position
which captures exaltation to the one
whom it is
to the one being bowed to
and it captures humility from the one
who is bowing
this is the purpose of right
and allah mentions
in the quran in this sense meaning the
spirit of
what is the spirit of he says
he says indeed your true
alliance and your true close
ones are allah and his messenger
and those who believe then he describes
the believers he says the ones who
establish
prayer give zakah also while bowing
what is meant by bowing meaning with the
utmost of humility
to allah and the utmost of exaltation to
allah
because it is a position of such
humility
it is not appropriate for the great
words of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
to be recited and this is why the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
prohibited that a person recite the
quran
this is not the appropriate position to
be reciting the quran
and so when a person makes
they have to attempt to epitomize their
humility
to allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in this
position you see the human being
is far more deep
and rich in emotion and in feeling
than what can be put into words we can't
always put into words the depth
and the richness of our emotions or the
shades of our emotion
and so some things cannot be said they
have to be done
right and so we express our
epitomized humility to allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
in the way that we position our bodies
this is the purpose of
if you have this in mind and you
understand this spirit
you will see that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
his method his fashion of making
sought to epitomize this as well so we
see that
[Arabic recitation]
go down into
he would spread his fingers on his knees
as if he was grabbing them right
mentions to us he would place his two
hands on his two knees
and almost as if he is grabbing onto
them so the fingers are spread apart
right the back is to be straight
and it is to be extended right
mentions that the prophet alaihi
wasallam would make
his back so straight and flat
and rule that if water to were to be put
on his back it would
stagnate on his back it wouldn't go any
direction because his back is so flat
right that it would capture capture that
water
likewise the head is neither up
nor is it dangled it is straight
with the back the arms are bent
and they are separated from
the stomach and the thighs so the arms
are bent
and they are out right we don't have to
exaggerate this too much
it is just enough that we spread away
from
you know we spread our body apart
they should not be this
and he's
completely at a 90 degree angle
with his body at the waist and there is
a narration in which he mentions that
the
of the one who does not flatten his back
that this roku is not valid
and so it is important that a person
make roku in this way
now if a person has some kind of
ailment that does not allow him
to be this limber that is a different
story but this is the
ideal position of making little court
this is how it should look right
and so there is if we notice the way
that he would make rokura his feet are
straight to the
qibla his hands grasping
his arms out right not too exaggerated
just out to where there's a gap between
the arms and the and the abdomen and
the back is straight the head is
straight we notice something what
is that there is no
articulation in this position of
laziness there is no articulation of
tiredness when a person is lazy they
kind of
allow their body to
kind of fall into a very lazy position
though
is not this and the reason for that
is that this is not
appropriate when we are making rookwor
unbowing to allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
he says speaking about
rising firmal court which we spoke
about last week
that
would say regarding a person making
he said to jesus
would rise from sujud and he would rise
up completely
until he his body had settled in the
standing position
right if a person makes rukur and comes
up somewhat
and then goes down this is not this
standing position is not valid
standing between rukur
and sujud is a pillar of prayer
a person must stand straight likewise
between sujud
after sujud between the two sajdah
a person cannot come up halfway and then
go back down into sujud
sitting between the two sajdah is a
pillar of prayer
and in this spirit the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam says
that no salah is going to be valid in
which the individual
does not fully erect his body
between rukur and sujud
right so a person must completely come
back
to the standing position and that
standing position
must you must come to a complete stop
to where your body settles into that
position
before you can go into another he says
wakana is
he says and
when he would finish and
reach to the standing position before
sujud he would say
oh our lord to you belongs all praise
there's a four ways that he would say
this
[Silence]
now we mentioned that the correct
opinion
is that when an individual rises from
rukur to the standing position he says
which translates to allah answers those
who praise
him so as you are rising just when
we were going down
in takbira till interqual we said it was
the transitional
[Arabic recitation]
akbar
and goes into rukur this is its
equivalent
in rising from rukur so now we say
[Arabic recitation]
once we reach the the standing position
now we say
[Arabic recitation]
understanding
this is something that is said by
everyone whether you are an imam
leading others or you are being led in
prayer or you are praying by yourself
all people who pray are going to say
both
[Arabic recitation]
rabbin or allah
or allah all four
are correct so the transitional
remembrance is
and then in this position now i'm in a
new position which is standing
between sujud now i am saying
oh allah our lord to you belongs all
praise
and this is appropriate because think
about what it is we're saying
we first recite the quran and we have
our hands
right hand over the left in a very
humble way we are standing we are
neither lazy
in our stance nor are we arrogant
and prideful in our stance the way the
prophet salallahu
we recite the quran with dignity this is
the
this is the standing position right the
great words of allah
and all of saleh revolves really around
recitation of the quran that's what
salah is really designed for
salah is really designed to
be a conducive
environment for the contemplation of
the quran
this is what salah is designed for allah
says
and establish prayer for my remembrance
meaning so that you may remember me and
so that you may recite my words
so we are reciting the quran we are
contemplating deeply what it is we are
reciting
[Arabic recitation]
after hearing these great and
magnificent
and noble words so rich in meaning
light upon light now we
react to those words
what is our reaction we bow out of
exaltation to allah
and humility in ourselves right
[Arabic recitation]
bowing position
subhanallah
perfect is he my great and greatest
lord right now after we have
reacted to those words of allah
we are so overcome by the words of allah
that
we must break ourselves literally
break our bodies almost in half fold
ourselves
to articulate
our great exaltation of allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
we are rising from that allah
answers those who praise him
our lord to you belongs all praise now
we pray
we are setting the stage for
sujud now because now we are going to
get into sujud and this is the place
where dua is most most
recommended because the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam said
the closest the human being is from his
lord is insulted
[Arabic recitation]
li muhammadan
and then we go into sujud and so it is
not arbitrary in the way that we make
saleh
it is designed that way to instill in us
a particular thing
and that we may exhibit a particular
thing he says
[Silence]
and the way that he would his
traditionally customarily the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would stand extensively after
rukur so the length of his rukur
would dictate the length of his standing
after rukur
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
customarily
based on how long he stayed in rakuw he
would stand
in a similar amount of time right
so as long as he was in court would be
as long as he is in
the standing position after rukur and
one of the dua that he would make after
[Arabic recitation]
he would make this beautiful dua which
we will translate
o allah our lord
to you belongs all praise the fill
of the heavens and the fill of the earth
and the fill
of all that is in between the fill
of anything after which you choose
you are one who is worthy of
greatness one who is worthy of the
greatest of descriptions
and the greatest of praise
you are the best of which
the servants have ever said or described
you with
and the best of what we have described
him with is what he taught us
he said and all of us to you is a
servant
there is nothing that will prevent your
giving
nor is there anything that will give
what you have prevented
nor can a person's own personal
abilities surpass your will
all will is from you he says
[Silence]
wash me of my sins with water
and ice and snow
and purify me and
clean me of my sins
just as a pure white garment
is close is cleaned and
rendered pure again and
distance between me and my sins
the distance that you have placed
between the east and the west
he says
and it is also authentically reported
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would repeat
in this position
and that he would repeat in the standing
position okay
and he would continue to say al-hamdu
to my lord belongs all praise to my lord
belongs all praise and that he would
continue to say this
as long as he is in this position the
same amount of time that he said
subhanallah
right so if it's ten times subhana rabbi
allah he would say
rabbi al-ham ten times in this standing
position
he says and
and the author of the
authentic compilation which is known as
muslim he has collected in his authentic
compilation on the authority of anas
who was the very close confidante
and servant of the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam from the
moment he came
to medina until he departed this world
anas narrates to us
that the messenger of allah
when he would say allah
answers those who praise him
so when he would move from the rokur
to the standing position he would say
semi-auto
and he would remain standing so long
that we those who were praying behind
him would think that he had forgotten
which position he was in right
yes
and he would also sit likewise between
the two sujud
so long that we praying behind him would
think that maybe he forgot what position
he was in
says this is what is known and
authentically reported and collected and
preserved
of the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's customary
ways in these positions
he says and as for making these two
positions
brief meaning after standing before
sujud
and sitting between the two sajdah
making these two pillars these two
positions of prayer
making them brief this is something that
started
in the government of beni umayya
which came after the death
of ali
some of the governors of that time
of beni omaya they started to cut
corners and these are some of the
corners that they cut
and so
he's saying that these two positions
this is how the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would behave in these
positions
in the standing between sujud
and in the sitting between the two
sajdah
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would make these positions
as long as he made the positions that
preceded them
and followed okay so if it's standing
the standing would be as long as the
court if it's sitting it would be as
long as the sujud
he says this is what is known and
authentically compiled
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's custom
during the in in performing these acts
in these two positions he says yet
making these two positions brief
in the midst of prayer so you're
standing for a long time
you make rokura for a long time you
stand very briefly
and then you go into sujud for a long
time you sit very briefly
time he said this
this kind of going over
these two positions with such brevity
this is something that
was not known in the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
it's not something that was happening
with the companions
rather this is something that some of
the governors of the government of beni
omega
the government of benio maya came
after the finality of the khilafah of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
the prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
that or
this my my successorship
of my prophethood will be for 30 years
after those 30 years it will turn into
a kingdom right and that is marked with
the
death of allah
and about six months of the life of
or the successorship of alhassan
after which he stepped down and
vacated for
and the capital was moved to damascus
to dimash and this is when the kingdom
and the government of benio mayma benny
umayyah
began to reign and so
the government of benio maya had
governors
and these governors they would lead the
prayer this is how it was
there was no separation as we say in
america
or in the west this concept of
secularism which is the separation
of church and state church being the
religious
and state being the political and social
this is not something that is a is an
islamic concept
this is something that is new to us
in islam the government
is both together right the beginning
stages
of islam during the successorship of the
prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
we see that they were the the leader was
one he
controlled the government and the
military arm of the government
and he also control controlled the
religious and so he was a scholar as
well
and a role model this continued but then
they separated and so we have the
scholars
and then we have the government or the
rulers
right the rulers are in charge of the
enforcement and the
scholars are the ones who are
commissioned with preservation of the
religion
and interpretation of the law
and so when this separation happened
it was still not it was still new
to people and so the way that it would
work is that you would go to prayer you
would pray behind the governor of your
area
and that governor would pray in a
particular way and we would take our
understanding of the religion from him
because it was one
but in the time of the government of
benio maya
it's split and so the governors were not
necessarily
as religious they were not as scholarly
they were not as knowledgeable
and it continues to separate today
right and it continues every single year
every single
generation to become further and further
and more distance
from each other unfortunately
as i've been tamiya rahim allah is
mentioned in in multiple places
throughout his works
so in the time of benio maya some of the
governors
started to cut corners in their worship
and these were some of the corners that
they would cut so
they would make rukur for a long time
stand up briefly and then go into sujud
and so they did this so often that
people praying behind them thought that
it was something that was part of the
sunnah of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam which it was not now
now we will move and transition into
the position of sujud he says
and he would move into the position
of sujud
and he would not raise his hands what
does this mean
meaning before we went into the court we
raised our hands after
we raised our hands but
he would not raise his hands again
he said and the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam would fall into sujud in the
following
manner his knees would go first
and then his hands and then his forehead
and then his nose in that order and so
that which is closest to the ground
would go first
this way right it's a difference amongst
the scholars
between was it correct to go on the
hands first or was it correct to go on
the knees first
abner kaiyam here tells us clearly that
it's the knees first and this is the
opinion of the majority
and it is also
you know oftentimes what is brought up
in this debate amongst the scholars is
the issue of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
prohibited that an individual
go into sujud as a camel
goes to sit down right
what is meant by this narration is not
what part of your body
touches the ground first that's not what
this narration is speaking about
this narration is actually speaking
about el haya
meaning rather you go on your knees
first or on your hands first
that you are not to fall down
in a way that is not smooth and
transitory right
so if you go on your hands really heavy
or if you're really heavy on your knees
this is not
this is this is not part of the sunnah
this is what the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
lam prohibited that a person do in
saleh
it's not about an individual
going on his hands or his knees in the
correct opinion
he says
[Silence]
foreign
the issue that we just discussed with a
little more detail
he says when the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would go into sujud
he would transition into sujud
the closest parts of his body first to
the ground
and then what follows okay
he says and the opposite is true when he
would raise
up from sujud so when he would go
into sujud his knees are closest to the
ground he would start with the knees and
then the hands
and then the forehead and the nose
until he would finally reach his
destination
when he would come up from exactly that
process in opposition
so he would begin with lifting his head
and then his hands and then his knees
he says and
this is the exact opposite of how
a camel goes to sit or to lay down
and he has generally prohibited that a
person
imitate any animals
in his salah okay so let's unpack that a
little bit
he says it is exactly the opposite of
what a camel does
if we notice a camel begins with
going down on the front
so when a camel goes to lay down it's
sitting this
when it goes to lay down it goes knees
first and then the back
not the knees it doesn't have knees i
mean the front
legs the front legs first and then the
the back opposite of the human being
when we go into sujud we go knees first
and then we don't drop
front first okay
he says this is specifically for going
into sujud we are not to imitate a camel
in the way that it goes to lay down
however in general the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
has prohibited the imitation of animals
in their
gestures during any part of the salah
so when we look at the body of
narrations we see that he has prohibited
going down that of a camel
and he has prohibited the movement of
the head a fox
what does that mean specifically
during salem when a person goes to make
taslim
a fox generally is a very smart
cunning and very nervous animal it's a
very nervous
animal as a matter of fact some hunters
in very cold areas the way that they
know
if a lake or a pond if the ice is
thick enough to walk on it is
they will look to see if a fox has
walked over that body of water or not
because a fox is so nervous
so paranoid that it would never walk
over
that lake that body of frozen water
unless it could
basically carry 10 times its weight
that's how
nervous it is and so the the nervousness
and the skittishness and paranoia of a
fox
cause it to look around very quickly
very rapidly with its head
right this is what is called iltifat
and so the fox will
move his head very quickly right left up
down
a person is not to do this in prayer in
any part of prayer but especially during
testimony
this is not prohibit this is not
permissible this is prohibited in prayer
rather we are not to imitate any animals
and a fox especially when we are making
our tesleem
he says
he said and he has prohibited that a
person
lay his forearms on the ground
as a beast does a beast meaning a
lion a tiger
a hyena any dogs that have their
that their front
their front limbs bend our elbows
right and that is that when a person is
in sujud
this part of the hand should never touch
the ground
right it is the caffeine the
part that comes in contact with the
ground should be
limited to the hands and the palms from
the wrist
on up to the forearm on up to the elbow
they should not touch the ground this is
what is called as
if the russia you see that
you know animals this cats dogs
whatever
when they lay when they sit they're
sitting with their hands
flat on the ground and their forearm
flat on the ground this
this is prohibited in sujood rather the
forearms must be
raised and we mentioned one of the
reasons for that a little bit ago
a he said and another thing that is
prohibited
is what is known as
the position that a dog sits in if you
notice a dog
when it sits it sits with its hands
between its legs the legs are coming up
here the hands are
together right here okay and
it is sitting flat on the ground and its
tail is coming out at the end when it's
sitting
this is prohibited in prayer
so one of the pillars of prayer
is that when a person met between the
two sujud
and for tashahud a person must be in the
sitting
position person must be in the sitting
position
now what is sitting anything that is
considered
sitting is permissible
anything that is considered sitting is
permissible except one type of sitting
and that is
that a person sit with their buttocks
flat on the ground
the feet and the knees coming up and the
hands in between this is called
this is impermissible in prayer as well
he says
another thing that is impermissible and
prayer
is pecking that of a crow
what does that mean that means that a
person's movement
especially the sujud be very
fast and swift right just like
a crow that is eating you know seeds or
something it will
it will peck at the ground pecking
is impermissible there has to be time
when you go into sujud your body has to
come to a full stop and rest in that
position
and then you will come up and come to a
full stop and your body must settle in
that position
and then you will go into sujud again
opposite of what a crow does
he says
he said and another thing which is
impermissible
is that a person flail his
hands when he is making tesleem like
that of
a horse a horse's tail right and that is
that
in sahih muslim the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
it was mentioned that some of the
companions when they would make taslim
their hands are on their knees this
and they would say assalamu alaikum
warahmatullah and they would
raise their hand this and then
assalamu alaikum
with allah and raise their hand like
this so he
he said do not move your hands that
of the tails of
horses when you make your tesleem do not
do this this is the context
some have in misinterpreted this
narration to mean
don't raise your hands before
and before sujud and et cetera et cetera
this is now what is intended by the
narration
the context of the narration is just
before teslim
the some of the companions were doing
this
so he prohibited this he said do not
wave your hands that
when you are making tesleem the
tails of
horses and this
is enough for today insha'allah
we will continue where we left off
next week we will be discussing
we will be discussing how the prophet
salallahu wasallam would make proper
sujud
and we will discuss some of the things
that he would say in sujud
some of the things that he would not say
and some of the etiquettes of
this is the most important position the
human being can ever be in
and so it's important that we get it
right
thank you very much for listening
in